the Sixers Al Horford and the NBA
teaming up to launch the first junior
NBA camp and sent to Domingo Dominican
Republic three day camp will host over
100 local boys and girls from across the
Dominican Republic the NBA and its teams
are reaching more than 1 million youth
in 75 countries to play league
basketball actually over 50 million
youths in 75 countries so it's a great
thing that Al Horford and the NBA are
teaming up to do and Al joins us on the
program al how are you today all right I
have to let you know that you're gonna
go into the Basketball Hall of Fame
all right I've crunched the numbers do
you know that you're going into the
Basketball Hall of Fame okay now it's
the Basketball Hall of Fame it's not the
NBA it's the Basketball Hall of Fame so
if I incorporate that out you want two
titles in college at Florida right yes
and you've been a five-time all-star is
that right yes okay here's the list of
players who have accomplished what
you've accomplished in your career Bill
Russell Gail Goodrich Kareem
abdul-jabbar and Grant Hill how about
that that's quite an honor to be named
among those guys okay are you gonna
start your speech writing your speech
now when when do you start to write your
speech and at what point do you mention
me in your speech you know what just
because you brought it up when that time
comes I will thank you thank you all
right now how easy of a decision was it
or was it easy for you to leave Boston
to end up in Philadelphia it was a very
difficult decision you know just looking
at everything that it had gone on you
know with the season and my time in
Boston you know was in a decision that
was taken lightly by me you know I
we thought that things were going to
work out a certain way and but Boston
and they did it and and yeah you know I
had to you know start looking at the
next step better but it was not easy we
had such great expectations for this
silted team this past year and I'm sure
you did too
what went wrong we had a lot of high
hopes for our group and I just think
that uh you know we never were able to
to jail like we needed to you know I
mean coming together as a group and I
and playing at that at the level
consistently that we needed to play you
know I felt like we did it at times and
and and you know our talent carried us
you know a lot of the times but we just
couldn't be consistent enough as a group
so that's that was definitely
disappointing what is your role in the
development of Joel embiid and Ben
Simmons if you're being asked to play a
role in that if anything we want to know
we want to wait um what I went now and
for me you know to support Joelle and
then you know in any way that I can to
help them you know get better see the
game more clearly you know I believe
that I'm able to you know to help them
with that and also obviously help them
you know on the floor or focuses on
whatever be a championship and in that
when I'm that's that's our mindset and
and as I talk to them that the week I've
talked about did you see where Danny
Ainge I think came out and accused the
76ers of tampering with you do you feel
tampered with out
ridiculous you know it is let me banish
I love that and you know daddy was
always really good to Bank and I know
that he's definitely frustrated with you
know they could work out with us tell me
what you're doing with the NBA and the
Dominican Republic you know with what
this camp is all about and how did you
get involved in it yeah so um you know I
thought some stuff throughout the years
of Dominican how to help the development
of basketball down there and NBA which
we started to to them and don't a bit
wanted them to be involved in any way
that they can help us and you know they
decided to bring the junior NBA program
over there and and we're gonna be there
for three four days and we're gonna have
clinics and you know we're gonna have a
host a tournament and it's going to be
kids from all over the Dominican and I'm
really excited about because it just
really gives me an opportunity to really
you know work spend spend some
one-on-one time with the kids and really
help them and encourage them and
hopefully motivate them so any type of
MBA get football I feel like it's it's a
game changer and for a lot of these kids
down there the there's a lot of
interesting basketball it gets them you
know that hope so you know it really
gets me excited best offensive player
you ever faced was who um I'd probably
say quite a few but I am I've always was
very impressed with Kobe you know it's
just going against Kobe that we did that
he was able to do on the floor and it's
very difficult offensive these I don't
think oh did he talk to you yeah I mean
that'd I'd I have to guard him but I
can't take credit for him you know given
us buckets that it was all those
impressive
you know to watch him you don't work but
did you ever have one of those helpless
moments on the floor where you're
guarding somebody and you know that no
matter what you do it doesn't matter
it's just not there yeah week over yeah
yeah no question about it with him and
the other guy that I had that actually
that happened if he was with on with
Yahweh when he played you know seven six
and you know there's no chance no matter
what what I was doing how much I was
bumping him you know he couldn't even
see me so oh yeah it's one of those
moments yeah you know how I wonder if if
y'all had been able to stay healthy
because people don't realize how big he
well he had a big base I mean his lower
body was I mean he was a huge guy we
look at Shaq is obviously a big guy
people forget y'all Ming was a big guy
not tall he was big that's what I was
telling people he was called you could
fool them and that cut so I mean imagine
if you know him obviously incidentally I
mean it'd be posted helping you were
also eager for the suit so he pursued
his big range at the time but now it be
three three and there's no way you know
you're affecting him at all so he was he
was a very special player I think like
he said people in quite realize how good
he was did you go and check yeah but I
was very lucky i guarded sac Ford when
he started to decline and it wasn't the
same track that you know it was putting
people in the rim you know they're
really cool hey al congratulations on
the move to Philadelphia and what you're
doing in the Dominican Republic and of
course when you get to the Basketball
Hall of Fame and a few years down the
road we'll see you there in Springfield
Massachusetts
Horford four more Dan Patrick show tune
in the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]